do you feel like you and D'Andra could
come together and be in the same place
so I've seen the premiere okay and you
and Deandra not starting off on the best
foot you come together at Stephanie's
and kind of have a let's bury it let's
start new a friend or vention yes yes
doesn't seem like that's gonna last I
will tell you our relationship is better
than any roller coaster in any country
my bar rich sent some text message to my
husband about some bullsh cheating
scandal that Haiti note is talking about
and this is how it read I'm going to
tell Deandra all about pretty Jessica
she's everything Deandra isn't I didn't
want to bro because I usually have
discretion but I will not tolerate the
baseless BS that your wife is spewing
about me there are some texts exposed
that were exchanged between rich and
Jeremy yeah we're rich alleged that
Jeremy had had an affair yeah I'm aware
of that text I was not a part of that
text I wasn't even in the room when he
sent it I think rich waited and waited
and waited all year the season was
airing he waited and he waited and he
waited for an apology and to this day he
still has not gotten an apology okay
do you think I've apologized to mark
doober sincerely with heartfelt and
tears yes there's a difference but the
mark situation how is that different
than from deandra alleging that it is
okay and I'm not trying to make this
situation different I'm trying to show
the example of the apology got it one
person delivered and continues to
deliver I continued every time I see
them to say you don't ever have to
forgive me I owe you this this is my
mistake I learned I was young I was
stupid I wasn't young but like in this
what we did is work in this world and
you know I believed what was said to me
by the way in Thailand she came to me
and told me who told her that they slept
with rich and it is a next dental
hygienist of riches that has had a crush
on him since before I met him has
actually been put into the psych ward
for this crush maximum you know
three-day hold in the psych ward and has
arrest records where she beat up her
husband so I'm so glad that that's who
you chose to believe over me okay so
we're gonna see all of this play out it
feels like those texts are going to be a
catalyst for some drama she never showed
me the text the entire season really
mm-hmm
interesting isn't it though yeah I mean
that's that's what I'm trying to say
like that's the messy part of messy
people if there's something that I have
to say I'm gonna say it to you because I
want to let you know that I how I feel
resolve the issue if I can apologize if
I've done something that offended you
that wasn't meant to offend you and move
the hell on I don't wait for you know
press or confessional or any of that
like Here I am let's speak maybe my
cojones are just a little bigger than
everyone else's I don't know you've said
that the end just really thinks before
she speaks she does would you go so far
as to call her calculate it oh for sure
I mean listen look at the woman who
raised her that'd be stupid I mean that
is calculation and manipulation in its
finest form with a cute wig on top
calculated in everything yeah
[Music]